the democrat majority in the house make
time hanging in the balance as two more
democrats announce they're not going to
seek reelection that brings to the
number of 25 the number of house
democrats not seeking re-election and
that is a huge number and i promised you
yesterday todd it would grow by a half
dozen it's grown by one since then
hey it's going it's keeping going here
to react former congressman from
wisconsin and fox news contributor sean
duffy to kevin's point there sean how
many retirements could you see from
house democrats before all is said and
done
well gentlemen good morning i think you
can probably see another 15 18 you know
retirements come our way and i think
it's important to note what's happening
with all the dem retirements one you
have people that are uh going to run for
higher office that are democrats so
they're leaving their seats but i think
the other two categories are interesting
you have you have a whole slew of them
that are leaving because they're afraid
they're going to lose their seats people
like ron kind in wisconsin sherry bustos
in illinois they know that this is going
to be a tough cycle and they're probably
not going to win so they're going to
leave
congress instead of lose but there's
another interesting point too you have
long long-term democrats who have saved
seats who are leaving and the question
is why well the minority is not fun
right in the minority after republicans
take power and actually treat the
minority like
democrats that treated republicans is
not going to be fun either here's the
problem the nancy pelosi has run the
congress like a dictatorship not a
democracy she hasn't respected minority
rights and so if republicans take over
and treat democrats like nancy pelosi
has treated republicans it is going to
be a horrible situation for democrats to
be in the minority so a lot of these
long-standing democrats are like listen
i've had enough i'm out i'm gonna go
spend time with my family
well let me uh let me pivot for just a
second sean great stuff by the way and i
think you're right sometimes what
happens is if you mistreat people and
then the power swings the pendulum
swings back it can happen to you as well
i want to get your take meantime on
what's happening up in one of the great
cities in america chicago public school
classes canceled in chicago after a
union vote your thoughts on what's
happening there
well my question becomes who's who's
running uh the ship here i mean is it is
it the teachers union is it the mayor
who's in charge and i mean that you
think that you wake up you know one
morning and the union says they're not
going to show up for work again this
throws you know a wrench into the plans
of families across chicago how do i can
i go to work today do i have to stay
home with the kids and do zoom um how
are my kids going to continue to learn
on zoom and not be you know in person
and all the the social consequences that
take place from being home and not
socializing with other kids so i mean i
think this is devastating uh for
families in chicago but the bottom line
is the mayor has to step up and start
pushing back on these unions and again i
think these teachers unions have way too
much power we have to start pulling it
back and say if you don't want to teach
that's fine we'll find someone else who
wants to step in and educate young
people as opposed to letting you sit
home in your pajamas
and sit on zoom for a couple hours a day
and call that teaching and by the way
you still get your full salary
yeah sean you're a parent of nine what
do you do when something like this
happens and bigger picture
what are we doing to the kids of america
so i mean again this is really hard for
parents and again the the the parents um
a lot of some of these parents don't
have choices right they both parents
work um they're not in you know
high-skilled jobs they they don't have
employers that'll necessarily go okay
take the day off because your kids are
home they could lose their job if they
lose if they stay home and they don't
get that income it's hard to pay bills
especially with inflation pay your rent
this is cataclysmic for the family but
for the kids todd i think you make a
really good point what's happening to
our kids i mean we've seen depression
and isolation we've seen as we've tested
the kids we've seen they're not
advancing like prior
years in school because they have been
stuck at home and so i think the
long-term consequences of at home
schooling is is is we i don't think
we've seen it all yet we're going to see
it in years to come and we're going to
look back at this time in american
history with the pandemic where we
haven't looked up for kids
our leaders haven't looked at the
science the kids are relatively safe
from the coronavirus and say this has
been a huge miss where we put politics
ahead of the lives and the futures of
this generation of students
and there's also the impact of
competition china's getting exactly what
they want and that is a horrible thing
on so many levels sean duffy we
appreciate your time as always thank you
sir